[Música]
a
escala en parís
aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 durante meses representantes del
ejército zapatista de liberación
nacional y miembros del congreso
nacional indígena de méxico han hecho
una gira por 30 países europeos llamada
gira por la vida hoy tenemos con
nosotros a uno de sus portavoces angel
sulub muchísimas gracias y bienvenidos
muchas gracias por la invitación bueno
porque sintieron la necesidad de hacer
esta gira y cuál es el balance que hace
pues el congreso nacional indígena de
méxico recibió la invitación del
ejército zapatista de liberación
nacional para acompañar con una
delegación de hombres y mujeres de
distintos pueblos indígenas de méxico a
esta gira por la vida para nosotros el
congreso nacional indígena pues es la
oportunidad de encontrarnos con otros
pueblos con otras organizaciones con
otros colectivos que se encuentran aquí
en europa que también están luchando
contra los despojos que también están
luchando por la defensa de sus
territorios por mejorar sus condiciones
de vivienda de trabajo es decir una
lucha por la vida de la misma manera que
nosotros en los pueblos indígenas
estamos luchando pues contra este embate
del sistema capitalista patriarcal y
colonial que vivimos angel sulub ustedes
de quintana roo y tienen un mensaje muy
preciso es la punta de lanza del
movimiento anti tren maya que recorrerá
1500 kilómetros por el sureste mexicano
pasará por los estados de chiapas
tabasco campeche yucatán y por su estado
quintana roo porque se oponen a este
tren bueno nosotros los pueblos mayas
decimos que no es un tren y que no es
maya no es un tren porque es únicamente
la articulación de una serie de mega
proyectos asociados al tren estamos
hablando de proyectos de desarrollo
turístico estamos hablando de
agroindustria estamos hablando de
empresas de energías eólicas y
fotovoltaicas y decimos que no es maya
porque no es un proyecto que haya
surgido de las necesidades del pueblo
maya ni para el beneficio del pueblo
maya entonces este tren para nosotros es
un proyecto que se está imponiendo en
nuestro territorio sin la consulta y el
consentimiento de nuestros pueblos habla
de las necesidades mayas cuáles serían
entonces cuáles serían esas necesidades
para nosotros desde nuestra forma de
mirar la vida desde nuestra forma de
concebir el mundo el bienestar es la
vida digna que nosotros estamos buscando
y esta vida digna tiene que ver con una
relación estrecha con la naturaleza y
armoniosa una relación que se rompe a
través de estos proyectos como es el
tren maya que tiene entre otros
objetivos la creación de 1616 nuevos
polos de desarrollo o 16 nuevas ciudades
que imitan el ejemplo de es cancún que
es una ciudad que se encuentra en el
estado de quintana roo y que pues para
las empresas y para el gobierno es un
modelo de desarrollo pero que para
nosotros para los pueblos ha sido un
modelo de devastación y de muerte el
tren maya iba a ser eléctrico pero
parece ser que al final también va a
funcionar con diésel o sea va a ser
mixto esto
provocará más contaminación no sé
ustedes han hecho algún tipo de
proyección sí bueno estamos hablando de
que va a ser un tren híbrido eso
significa que seguirá el consumo de
hidrocarburos pero lo más importante es
no centrarnos únicamente en el tren y en
el proyecto de transporte sino en todo
lo que está alrededor del tren es decir
muchas veces tratan de que nos centremos
únicamente en el ferrocarril sin embargo
el impacto ambiental el impacto social y
el impacto cultural va mucho más allá de
la construcción
y tiene que ver con todo lo que lo que
está alrededor todo lo que traerá en la
construcción del tren justamente sobre
el impacto ambiental en el presidente
dijo que no iba a haber deforestación
pero parece que ya hay 144 hectáreas que
se han deforestado si en los últimos
sobrevuelos por parte de organizaciones
que acompañan la defensa legal que
llevamos los pueblos mayas se detectaron
alrededor de 144 hectáreas que han sido
deforestadas
en lugares forestales sin los permisos
correspondientes y que también están
desacatando
disposiciones judiciales como
suspensiones provisionales que hemos
logrado a través de amparos lo que
estamos viendo es que pues hay una
devastación ambiental en la construcción
y bueno lo que vendrá al final con todo
lo que las ciudades nuevas que se
quedarán pues también le quería hablar
de los jaguares porque parece que es una
especie que se podría extinguir en
mexico pero se están
pensando en hacer corredores para únicos
ustedes qué piensan de estos y estas
medidas que el gobierno le llama de
mitigación que son unos pasos de fauna y
pensamos que son totalmente
insuficientes es decir la fragmentación
que se que se que se vivirá en estos en
estas reservas naturales como es la
reserva de la biosfera de calakmul en el
estado de campeche pues provocará daños
irreversibles al al entorno me hablaba
hace un momento de los recursos
jurídicos cuantos recursos hay
interpuestos hay alrededor de 19 y
recursos jurídicos que pues los pueblos
las comunidades y las organizaciones
hemos interpuesto por la violación a
nuestros derechos por la violación a los
derechos ambientales por la violación a
los derechos de consulta y de
consentimiento de los pueblos indígenas
por la violación a los derechos de salud
y otros derechos que se están
violentando y sin embargo vemos que
estos recursos judiciales
no están marchando de acuerdo a lo que a
lo que debería ser no vemos que el
sistema judicial mexicano no permite un
acceso efectivo a la justicia de los
pueblos indígenas o sean que los están
retrasando y una agresión hay una
dilación de los procesos judiciales hay
procesos o amparos que llevan más de 15
meses en el poder judicial sin siquiera
ser admitidos por un juzgado el tren
maya tiene como objetivo desarrollar más
actividad económica
con eso tal vez una mejora de las
condiciones de vida de los pobladores yo
ya entiendo que ustedes no están de
acuerdo con ese modelo que querrían otro
pero bueno según el gobierno se han
generado en muchos puestos de trabajo
90.000 porque estar en contra de eso si
el argumento central del gobierno es la
generación de empleos y en cuanto a ese
punto podemos ver que es real se
generaron esos empleos y se generarán
muchísimos más empleos pero la pregunta
que nos hacemos es qué tipo de empleos
son y para quién es lo que nosotros
vemos es que en los centros turísticos
los empleos para el pueblo maya son
empleos precarizados son empleos en
donde el pueblo maya es simplemente la
servidumbre de la industria turística
entonces eso es lo que cuestionamos que
esos empleos no dignifican la vida del
pueblo no es un poco contradictorio
denunciar bueno que por décadas en estas
zonas se nos ha olvidado un poco no las
comunidades y por fin hay un proyecto
faraónico hay inversión y de plano
rechazarlo sí bueno es que los pueblos
mayas en realidad lo que exigimos es el
respeto a nuestros derechos de autonomía
y de auto terminación es decir que nos
permitan decidir cómo queremos vivir
como queremos organizarnos qué es lo que
queremos para nuestros territorios y
estos proyectos muy grandes faraónicos
como dices son proyectos pensados desde
otro lugar nos surgen desde el pueblo
maya entonces son proyectos que al final
se imponen en nuestros territorios
ustedes también denuncian la
militarización del sudeste mexicano es
cierto que los militares están
construyendo y van a administrar el tren
maya
según el presidente andrés manuel lópez
obrador es para evitar justamente su
privatización cuál es el posicionamiento
del cine y pues nosotros lo que vemos es
justamente que este tipo de proyectos no
son para el beneficio de los pueblos no
son para el beneficio de la sociedad
sino son para el beneficio del poder en
este caso del poder militar y podemos
observar que en este gobierno de andrés
manuel lópez obrador el poder hacia los
militares en todo el país ha aumentado
sobre todo en los territorios indígenas
entonces lo que lo que observamos es
precisamente que este es un proyecto que
no beneficia a nuestro de qué manera
está afectando esa militarización bueno
tenemos hostigamiento tenemos represión
a los defensores y defensoras del
territorio además de que la presencia
militar pues es una intimidación directa
hacia las comunidades no se genera una
situación de violencia para luego
imponernos la militarización hay que
recordar que las ciudades de cancún
playa del carmen tulum son ciudades
violentas son ciudades en donde el
crimen organizado pues tiene el control
del territorio vemos que los cárteles
del narcotráfico el turismo sexual los
feminicidios están cada vez en aumento
en estos territorios que son para el
gobierno el ejemplo y el modelo de
desarrollo que se debe llevar a todas
las regiones de la península a través
del tren maya entonces esa es otra de
las razones por las cuales nosotros nos
negamos a este megaproyecto porque lo
que nos trae para los pueblos es la
muerte física de nosotros como seres
humanos y también una muerte cultural y
de identidad como pueblos ha habido
asesinatos de gente de la comunidad por
oponerse al tren
pues ha habido mucho hostigamiento y
mucha represión también ha habido un
asesinato vinculado de una manera
indirecta pero que tiene que ver con con
la imposición de este megaproyecto y lo
que vemos es el incremento de la
represión y de la intimidación hacia los
defensores y defensoras las obras del
tren maya han permitido el
descubrimiento de más de 16.500
vestigios en los primeros cuatro tramos
del tren vestigios que forman parte de
la cultura y de la historia maya por
ejemplo el sac btr de cacalchén en
yucatán una vía pavimentada de 33
kilómetros el segundo camino blanco eso
quiere decir sacven o más grande del que
se tenga conocimiento bueno las obras no
traen no todo es malo lo que traen las
obras se están descubriendo en vestigios
de su cultura si es que nuevamente nos
enfrentamos a esta palabra de
descubrimiento que es una palabra
totalmente colonizadora como el
descubrimiento de américa es decir para
los pueblos estos caminos antiguos
caminos blancos estos vestigios de
nuestros sitios sagrados pues están
presentes en nuestros pueblos y los
conocemos entonces pensamos que es algo
que no necesita ser descubierto no si no
se necesita ser respetado ya que ustedes
ya conocían por ejemplo este es zac bet
de cacalchén o la gente de yucatán ya
sabía que estaba ahí la firma le bueno
pues vamos a terminar con estos 25 años
del congreso nacional indígena que se
acaban de cumplir y yo le quería
preguntar ya a ver brevemente antes de
terminar un poco el balance que hacen de
sus actividades bueno somos una
delegación de 16 personas de diferentes
pueblos indígenas de méxico del pueblo
totonaca maya rarámuri purépecha nahua y
bueno hemos estado recorriendo distintos
lugares de esta geografía en europa y
nos hemos encontrado con muchas
organizaciones muchos pueblos muchas
comunidades que también están
resistiendo nos hemos encontrado por
ejemplo en alemania con que se está
resistiendo a la imposición también de
un megaproyecto de la dolce band que
también está participando en el tren
maya entonces hemos encontrado muchas
muchas similitudes hemos encontrado aquí
en francia una resistencia contra el
saqueo de agua por parte de empresas
como danone que también en méxico están
saqueando el agua y también en mexico
hay resistencia contra estos
megaproyectos y también nos hemos
encontrado con hombres y con mujeres que
están luchando por la vida que están
luchando por mejorar las condiciones de
vida de los pueblos en el campo y en la
ciudad y hemos encontrado entonces que
esta resistencia y estas luchas de los
pueblos están en en esta geografía al
igual que en la nuestra bueno pues ángel
sin luz portavoz del congreso nacional
indígena de mexico muchísimas gracias
por haber venido hasta nuestros estudios
muchas gracias y muchísimas gracias a
todos ustedes por habernos acompañado ya
saben que nos pueden seguir por internet
en rf y mundo.com bien france24 puntocom
hasta pronto amigos
[Música]